the trainees here are among the lucky
few
johannesburg's artisan training
institute turns unskilled laborers into
skilled workers
they've been sent by their employers in
south africa good vocational training is
still more the exception than the rule
instructor cindy malagi faults the
nation's school system
they've been through to the college but
because of the way they train them there
they don't get much
understanding there so we have to do
extra courses
give additional knowledge so that they
can
broaden enough
south africa's post-apartheid government
has been widely criticized for the
inadequacies of the country's training
system
workers and employers both stand to
benefit from improvements to it
south africa needs some ten thousand new
trained specialists each year but is
still far from being able to provide
them
the country needs many more people like
dumaso shalembe his parents managed to
give him a good education now many doors
are open to him
once i'm done here i'll be a qualified
electrician
and after that it will enable me to
become
an engineer actually it's easier to
become an engineer while you do have a
trade certificate
so yeah i want to see myself as an
engineer one day
hopefully very soon so it was
madison yatakazi has made a profitable
business from the skilled labor shortage
a training center she and a partner
started in johannesburg
now 400 south african and international
firms are sending their workers here for
further training
i come from an educational background
and i was approached to
be part of a technical training
center and we decided to buy the
technical training center ourselves and
because of the passion
they already have in developing people
it was amazing for for us to be part of
developing people in this field
and she's predicting continued growth
for her institute
it focuses on training electricians
metal workers and machine fitters
many of its clients are from the mining
industry one of south africa's
traditional economic mainstays
companies in the entire sector send
talented people here
among them is the german liebherr group
the equipment manufacturer is profiting
from africa's mineral resource boom
new mines are opening and need equipment
says the head of liebherr africa dieter
schmidt
we have seen in the last few years that
there is a move
from south africa into africa we are
selling a lot more machines nowadays
into africa
we have fully fledged organizations in
in ghana
where we are in the gold mines busy we
have got a fully fledged organization in
nigeria and since a few years we are in
mozambique where we are very busy in the
coal sector
and as we speak we are busy establishing
ourselves in the copper belt in sembia
liebherr also needs good workers
among the training center's graduates is
lindaway kanye
now liebherr's only female machine
fitter
it's six years already at libra
so it's nothing that breaks me off
i motivate myself daily that i wanna
bring the guys
down
the heads to start to believe that
ladies also
they can't do this job it's nothing
difficult
everything it has to be in your head
lindaway personifies south africa's
expanding middle class and yet there are
still far too few people like her in the
20th year after the end of apartheid